we always love when this happens here
because Oprah is about to reveal her
next book club section selection is how
it's pronounced only on CBS mornings
what is she talking about this time
hello CBS mornings I'm here to share my
next book club selection as we enter
fall with a slight crisp in the air and
the leaves starting to turn our next
book club selection is perfect to curl
up with set in the mountains of the
Southern Appalachians from the very
first sentence you're going to be
intrigued by this epic story of this
young boy demon Copperhead by Barbara
King salbert I'm so glad that she's
there with you today to share more about
how she crafted this beautiful
incredible story so get your copy today
and join us online at Oprah's Book Club
to share your thoughts happy reading
everybody Barber King solver
happy reading is the word there Barbara
King solver is the author of 11
best-selling books Barbara look at them
all lined up looks pretty doesn't it wow
11 best-selling books and former
President Bill Clinton awarded her the
National Humanities medal back in 2000
and we're very proud to say very happy
to welcome we're here to CBS Minds hello
Barbara King solver good to have you in
the studio this is so exciting you have
done it again you've done it again Bravo
to you when I first heard about the book
this is how Oprah said it's me she said
I found a book that even you're gonna
like I don't know if I should be
insulted or flattered by that because I
don't always like all of them but she
was so right from the moment that from
the very first sentence you drew me in
but you said you can you you use this
book you compared this book to Dickens
to tell this story explain what you mean
well this is I come from Southern
Appalachia so you know this area I know
that well very much and I love it and
Appalachia also has its challenges and
one of them in recent decades is the
opioid epidemic yes and the worst of it
is that we have a generation of kids
who've been orphaned by opioid use
disorder and you know as sort of the
attention of the world moves on I really
really wanted to tell the story of these
kids because it's not over for them and
they they live among us I know you know
we all know these kids but it's a dark
story and it's a hard story to tell it
is I wasn't sure readers would want to
go there follow me into that dark place
and so I spent actually a couple of
years
trying to get trying to find my way into
that house you know how to tell the
story as it happened Copperhead is a
person uh we should say that yeah the
real name is Damon yeah yeah his
nickname is demon demon and he's called
Copperhead because of his red hair
that's his nickname where I come from
Everybody Has nicknamed yeah it's a
thing but um so I was really frustrated
and just by chance at the end of a UK
book tour I had a weekend free and I
booked myself into this just completely
on a whim this Inn that's in broadstairs
it's the the former home of Charles
Dickens and it's where he wrote David
Copperfield Yeah and um so my husband
and I you know booked ourselves in and
we we had it was this creaky old mansion
on the ocean and we had it all to
ourselves and they said sure sure you
know make use of the place to sit
wherever you want including dickens's
study wow and so I I sat there I mean
Steven went to bed you know and I I sat
at dickens's desk wow looking out the
window at the view that he you know the
roiling ocean that was in his eyes and I
just started feeling his anger not at me
yeah but sort of the anger he channeled
in his books because orphans kids thrown
away by Society that's his whole
wheelhouse you are inspired yeah well it
was we're like he he he charged me with
this Mission he said you got to do this
yeah but it seems like everything that
could happen to demon does happen to him
well what he told me which was the the
the the key to get into the house was
you let the child tell the story nobody
doubts the child it's just that's the
way you tug on the the reader's heart
and um
and that was David Copperfield starting
with chapter one I am born I said okay
Charles thank you I sat at that desk and
I started this book that night and I
decided something thank you well thank
you no thank you because you take us on
quite a ride
I'm not going to tell you how it ends
but boy it's something Barbara we thank
you demon Copperhead is on sale now
wherever you like to buy books we'll be
right back congratulations second time